[Music]
just stand right here can you see this
time
we tried to get the lights oh yeah yeah
okay we're going to get and get started
we're going to introduce each speaker
we're going to have english followed by
spanish hold all questions to the end
to start off we have the governor ronda
center
good afternoon i've been able to
meet with a lot of our first responders
was able to go over with the fire chief
and
look at some of the work that's been
done as we've done in many days
and i know a lot of people are
looking at that with baited breath as we
all have been for many many days
and people ask you know what is there
hope or
or what's going to happen and the way i
look at it as a
as an old navy guy is you know when
somebody's missing an action in the
military you're missing until you're
found
and we don't stop the search and so i
think that that's what's what's
happening
those first responders are breaking
their back
uh trying to find anybody they can
and they are going to continue to do
that and they've been very selfless they
put themselves at risk to do it
uh and i i thought about that and then
having met this morning with many of the
many families who've um yeah this has
turned up
upside down the worlds of uh of a lot of
really great people not only in this
state
but but beyond and to hear the stories
of of the folks who are in the towers
who
either passed away or are missing the
amount
of i think sympathy that's been pouring
in is emblematic of some of the lives
that many of these people have had been
leading
they have touched people all across this
world
not just here in southern florida and
not just throughout the whole state of
florida
and um you know it's been um it's it's
been very heartbreaking and very
touching because there's a lot of folks
who've uh
have been experiencing some unbelievable
pain and uh the folks that
have either passed away or who are
missing uh are
almost invariably incredibly special
people
uh who've made a huge impact on not only
this community but communities
all across the country and all across
the world and so
when those guys are out there breaking
their back on that pile when they're
digging tunnels and putting themselves
in harm's way
to try to find a void to try to find an
area where they could potentially rescue
people
um they have that mission and they're
doing it and they're not jerking from it
because they understand that in every
one of those condominium buildings
were people uh whose uh
our different families world were
revolved around them
grandmothers grandkids uh brothers and
sisters
and um i just thank them for all their
efforts
and um i thank them for leaving no no
stone unturned
and the families uh we're gonna be there
for the long haul on this and we're just
not going to look back and we're going
to be there with any support
that we can provide thank you
thank you governor we're going to have
lieutenant governor jeanette nunez
in spanish
good afternoon i'll reiterate what the
governor said in spanish
is
is
thank you lieutenant governor and now
the mayor of miami-dade county the
honorable daniela lavinkava
here we are day six and the search and
rescue
continues it continued throughout the
night throughout the morning
there are currently 210 people working
on the mound the urban search and rescue
team
has been augmented by
teams from all over the state and all
over the world
they are working throughout inclement
weather
they're they're working as hard as they
ever have
but they are able to make headway even
in the face of
all of those obstacles so they're
continuing with the 12
hour shifts they take breaks they're
monitored
medically and and just to make sure
that they can get back safely on the
mound because it is such
painstaking grueling work i cannot
express enough how grateful we are
for their service their sacrifice their
passion
they live to save lives and that is what
we are
witnessing their bravery under extremely
difficult circumstances
continuing and continuing we are also
so very grateful for everyone who has
joined us in this effort
global teams state teams and national
teams on standby
for us so that we can relieve the
wonderful men and women
out there we truly have the best
in the world conducting this effort
the federal teams of the usar search and
rescue personnel
are rotating in with our current teams
there are more than sufficient personnel
on site we do not need
additional resources we have the best
and we have sufficient what we need to
get this job done
since our last briefing no new
fatalities have been confirmed
but we have been able to notify each of
the 11
families who have lost their loved ones
this is very very important that the
notification has been able to occur
and we're grateful to our miami-dade
police department
for their their very sensitive handling
of this difficult matter and all the
names have been released
to the public through our social media
platforms
and today we were also very grateful to
learn that our president
joe biden will be visiting surfside on
thursday
he's going to spend time with the
families who are affected and with our
first responders
we've had his support since he called me
day one in the morning
and this is so critical
that we do have our federal support so
we
we are very very grateful for that and
uh
and we know that his support will
continue throughout i also
want you to know that i've been in close
touch with our state attorney
catherine fernandez rundle and i am very
supportive of the grand jury
investigation that she has announced
i have pledged my full cooperation as
she moves forward i have worked closely
with grand juries in the past i'm very
familiar with the process and
i will do and my team will do everything
possible to aid them
in their efforts uh to continue that
uh investigation as i mentioned
yesterday
our building audit also continues and
we're taking
swift action to immediately identify and
address
any outstanding issues with the
buildings that have not yet completed
their 40-year certification process
that's our priority right now
and just last night our building officer
notified one of those properties a
building in northeast aid
that four balconies must be immediately
closed
to residents due to safety conditions so
we are
preceding a pace with all of the
buildings identified
and i know within a matter of days or
short
weeks we will have addressed all of
those safety concerns
and today i am also making an
announcement
that i will be meeting with subject area
experts
from multiple relevant fields from
engineering to legal to construction
to development to soil to geology
to look closely at
every possible angle on this issue
related to building safety
so we they will advise me on issues
related to building construction
chain of custody and requirements for
reporting condominium regulation
and more so that my staff and i can
develop a
set of recommendations for changes that
need to be made
at all steps in the building process to
ensure a tragedy like this
will never ever happen again
and i will be meeting with these experts
in the very near future
and i will be planning to look for
additional experts
who can advise me once further insights
are achieved
from this investigation so we'll
continue to pull in
additional experts as new information
becomes
available to ensure that we're
considering all possible
angles all possible factors and
perspectives
for the families who've been impacted by
this tragedy
we are continuing to do all that we can
to support them in any way
that they need so our new expanded
family assistance
center has over 20 agencies now offering
support short and long-term counseling
home assistance travel assistance
psychological and grief counseling
financial assistance visa and passport
support
and much more works in addition legal
support
and we're going to continue to offer our
twice daily briefings to the families
and we just completed our morning
session before this conference
these sessions have been vital to
assisting families to understand
the nature of the search the nature of
the entire enterprise
and this is so so important as we
proceed daily
on our search and rescue efforts to have
them fully
aware of every step of the process so
please
i know you join with me in your prayers
your wishes your hopes during this
incredibly difficult time
for our families
[Music]
families
aristas
a
thank you madam mayor let me introduce
the deputy incident commander charles
cyril
good afternoon under the leadership of
the mayor
miami-dade county is coordinating and
unified
through a unified search rescue and
assistance efforts
consisting of multiple county
departments such as hardware fire rescue
moderate police department water and
sewer
durham isd county attorney's office
and much others in addition to our
federal
state local international and
not-for-profit organizations
this has led to a seamless integration
of these resources
throughout the event we continue to
prosper and utilize these agencies
up to 60 at this time and over 800
responders who are supporting this
effort
integrating into our unified response
and ensuring
a successful search and rescue effort
thank you
now the director of the florida division
of emergency management kevin guthrie
good morning everyone as far as state
resources to update well first of all
because of the weather we have the new
tent system
uh which i'm sure you guys will
appreciate in addition to that
we have over 440 state employees
involved in on-site
response efforts those 440 do include
the state emergency response team-led
mutual aid
search and rescue teams we will we
continue to provide
assistance through items such as a
laundry trailer as
restroom trailers shower trailers
jackhammers
buckets air compressors and many many
more
the florida division emergency
management logistics team will continue
to support
all resource requests as of this is more
as of this morning we have 29
individuals who have registered with
fema's individual assistance program
currently there are 22 organizations
that are assisting
i want to go ahead and let you know that
fema has advised being
through the administrator that virginia
task force one virginia task force ii
and ohio task force one are on standby
awaiting any type of resource request
that we may need again i think it's
appropriate to reiterate mayor cava's
point
that we have all the resources we need
we do not need anyone to self-deploy
and help us we have plenty of resources
in reserves
ready to respond the florida department
of transportation as you see the dump
trucks this morning
have started to assist with moving
debris to an alternate site
and they will continue to do so the
florida the florida department of
management services
continues to search with a warehouse for
a warehouse for resource
donations the florida department of
children and families is coordinating
with miami-dade county
to distribute gift cards for displaced
individuals
additionally as a reminder the florida
department of highway safety motor
vehicles has deployed two of their
mobile units here
for no no fee cost speed free
driver's license and identification
cards vehicle registrations and titles
to the independent or to the impacted
individuals but i need to remind you
that those
hours on those mobile units are from
11am to 5pm
at the family assistance center florida
department highway safety motor vehicles
is also coordinating with the red cross
to identify any
impact individuals needing additional
assistance we know that this is a
difficult time for families and first
responders involved
in the rescue and recovery efforts
please know that florida is here to help
you
and i thank the governor lieutenant
governor for their leadership and
allowing us to respond and do what we
need to do
without any hesitation i want to remind
you if you cannot find the resource that
you're looking for
you can always call florida's 2-1-1 and
we will get you to the site that you
need to be
associated with the state's priority
right now is to ensure
the county's needs are being met fdm
personnel will continue to remain on the
ground to assist
with all response efforts until we are
no longer needed thank you
thank you director and now for the
department of economic opportunity
secretary dane eagle
good afternoon everyone as you all know
the governor has been making sure that
state resources are available where
needed i was boots on the ground with
him
on thursday day one to assess the
situation and since then department of
economic opportunity sent two mobile
units down here
over the weekend now this once bustling
community has shut down not only to
mourn
but to make way for the first responders
so that they can do what they need
to service this community and of course
continue the search and rescue mission
now we've spoken with dozens of
businesses who are putting their needs
aside and servicing these first
responders whether it be through food
we've talked to cafes or small barber
shops we're offering free haircuts
now while they're doing that they're not
having their usual business so there is
a need there that needs to be met
we are trying to assess that need and we
need the media's assistance in doing so
you can send local businesses and the
businesses in the area to
floridadisaster.bids
floridadisaster.biz now the state is
also requesting the assistance
of the small business administration at
the federal level we've been in
communication with them
we hope to draw down some additional
funds but those surveys that these
businesses can assess
and do on the online will help us uh
help to bring down those funds
as we continue to help those who are
suffering not only the families but the
local businesses
who are serving our first responders
thank you to the governor the local
community
and the federal government for stepping
up to assess this need
thank you mr secretary and now the
server side mayor charles marquette
good morning i would just like to add a
few things uh
talk about my i walked the site this
morning and tell you what i saw
we had overnight there were issues with
some debris falling off the building
the west side of the pile had to be
cordoned off a little bit
because it was becoming excessively
dangerous to work there
what has happened is i understand the
work still continues from the sides and
underneath
but uh that area was cordoned off until
they can sort of
get their arms around the debris that's
falling down the second thing is
they've made very good progress on the
east end it's it's apparent
that they've got the pile down to the
point where you can see into the parking
lot
so there is great progress lastly with
respect to the site
uh there is an overwhelming amount uh
there are an overwhelming amount of
workers
rescue workers on the site working
and with cranes and and taking off
debris and
the work continues uh i attended the
family meeting this morning
it was it was informative the israelis
had announced that
they were going to be bringing in
additional
workers which made the families rescue
workers which made the families
obviously i could tell that there was a
there was more relief
in the room uh there was frustration
there was a little anger um there was
some there were questions about
why the work has to stop when there's
rain thunderstorms and lightning
the police chief or the fire chief
addressed that issue
and said that he would further
he would talk to the higher ups about
whether or not that worked because
it was an interesting comment because
the speaker said that they're already
risking their lives anyway they're
working under a building that could fall
down why do we have to stop for
lightning
um it was an interesting question and
the chief said he would get back to them
um
one of the other questions by the family
members was
how long can people survive under the
rubble
which was which was an excellent
question and uh
there there didn't seem to be a good
answer to that
i had uh several days ago sent mayor
cava a copy of an article that i was
sent
which dealt exactly with that point
and i thought it was very important to
let the family members know
so i stood up and i talked about what i
knew in the
what i knew from the article and it
talked about there were there were
several different instances but the most
notable
was the one from may 2013 where a woman
was pulled
from the ruins of a factory in
bangladesh 17 days
after it collapsed so
i i think as the governor said uh
earlier nobody in the
in the lieutenant governor nobody's
giving up hope here
nobody's stopping the work goes on
full force we're dedicated to get
everyone
out of that pile of rubble and reunite
them
with their families uh we have all the
resources we want i've been saying this
since the beginning we don't have a
resource problem we have a love problem
and as you know
we just got dumped on by some rain but
thankfully it looks like that's clearing
but the work will go on
we will continue to work at 100 thank
you you mayor
and for the border county commission
chairman honorable jose diaz
thank you um as you all know the mayor
the governor lieutenant governor and
other involved already said the
particulars
i simply want to say thank you to all of
you for
doing the reports in a very humane and
proper way
and doing it in a way that it was full
of information for people
which is important i want to thank you
from all of us from my colleagues and i
uh that is very important the world is
looking
and your news and what you're putting
out
is what's going on and and i'm very
proud that i've been to a lot of
proportionate
disasters and sometimes you really can't
watch the news because the way it's
presented
and i will tell you that i'm very proud
of all of you
in the work you've done as i am proud of
the first responders
as all have stated and one of them that
we haven't mentioned too much grouped
out is the police
i really want to thank them for the work
that day county
police and all the police agencies that
stepped it up from the cities
are doing and every level the chief the
director that is here
and everybody else so i want to thank
them
and all the other departments
excellent
foreign
thank you mr chairman miami-dade fire
rescue chief alan pemister
good afternoon we continue to search
grid layer by layer
removing debris as we continue to move
forward in our search and rescue efforts
as we mentioned before this is a very
tedious effort
it's devastating what occurred in
regards to the collapse and what we're
seeing
we're moving debris piece by piece and
searching through
we moved over approximately 3 million
pounds of concrete
at this time which equates to over 850
cubic feet
we have all the state florida task
forces here deployed
we have a federal task force on standby
as well as had the federal
incident support team arrived today
again extremely difficult just when we
first arrived and what we saw
the horrific catastrophic type of
collapse
of miami-dade fire rescue we were able
during that time frame to remove 37
individuals
37 individuals and we continue searching
with all our assets and all our support
assets all the task force is here in
florida
as well as the federal on standby and we
will continue to move through
i want to emphasize when we started this
search it's extremely difficult to what
we saw what we encountered
we deployed our search teams based on
what we evaluated and what we saw
in regards to highest probability and as
we've been mentioning time and time
again with our searches
those are the key things we look for
constantly running with our
canines our live dogs searching for hope
of life
using different audible equipment as
well as video equipment
searching for life that's what we've
been doing from the get-go and then we
re-evaluate and keep assessing
as we mentioned in regards to the grids
how we have it deployed now with our
large equipment that's here
and all our different task force 24
hours a day we have over 200
task force members made up of miami-dade
fire rescue
florida task force one and then all the
remaining florida task force
non-stop around the clock searching
it's a methodical very difficult process
you know as we're removing
debris we're just finding more debris
that's just
concrete pulverized you know it's it's
extremely difficult
as we mentioned in regards to looking
through void spaces looking for key
signs i want to be clear i mean we
haven't been seeing this
you know we come across small and we
keep moving we keep moving
we keep trying from the get go from what
we saw
devastated okay but we continue moving
forward
and continue pushing and we'll we'll see
if we you know where we're at at the end
thank you chief and now to give some
comments in spanish pio from many day
fire rescue eric benitez
is
is
is
gracias
thank you eric i'm from the mandate
police department chief of strategic
response division
at gardo caneva
hello everyone we've uh we have a small
update on our traffic plan just on my
new change
our new plan has been communicated with
our public safety partners and our city
officials
and is also posting on social media so
new closures today
is going to be collins avenue from eight
one street
to 91 street and from harding from 81
street to 96th street
we do have checkpoints at abbott and
96th street
and at harding and 96th street and let
me re-emphasize again that
residents specifically within the 33154
zip code and also employees
business owners employees of hotels
customers will be allowed access
please bear with us we understand the
challenges
and be patient and we'll we'll get this
result as soon as we can
eventually we're still re-evaluating on
a daily basis and ultimate goal at some
point will be the open
hearting happen
um
thank you chief and for the american red
cross ryan logan
good afternoon so the red cross
continues to coordinate with our
community and local
partners as well as our government
agencies to provide support to this
community
currently we have over 125 volunteers
and staff
on the ground for providing highly
trained and highly skilled support
in addition while our main priority is
really focusing on the entire community
one of our main focuses at this current
moment is to provide assistance to those
survivors directly impacted from the
champlain south
tower we are asking for individuals from
that tower if they have not done so
already
to meet with the red cross at the family
assistance center that the mayor
mentioned earlier
as well as if there are any survivors
that are
staying with loved ones or friends or
family outside of the area
we ask that they contact the local red
cross wherever they are
who will put them in contact with us
here on the ground so that we can make
sure that we can assess
and ensure that they have what they need
for this immediate phase of their
recovery
as i mentioned earlier in the week uh i
want to just reiterate
we know how this affects the emotions
of folks both here locally and afar
and so as a result we are working with
our local community partners to
offer some free emotional
things where we will be providing those
free courses to the community
so it'll be a great opportunity for
folks just to assess themselves
but also learn how to recognize the
signs of
trauma or the impacts in their own
family as well as how to speak to their
children about things like this so i
would just encourage you guys to
be on the lookout for that information
as we get the actual dates and locations
arranged for that thanks
thank you mr logan we're going to go
into questions and answers now
and we appreciate your cooperation so
far in all these press conferences
so wait until you're being selected
please address the person who you're
going to question
so that way that person can come forward
and immediately following the questions
and answers we're going to go to the
creole translation
so the grand jury has not yet been
impaneled
so i was speaking to the
state attorney this morning about it and
we were talking about
whenever it is moving forward that we
will be fully on board she has announced
that she will be asking
the grand jury to look at this matter
i'm sorry what will it mean
like all of us answers
any of the spanish media got a question
so we can all welcome you here spanish
for again
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
so residents are talking us about
those that evacuated pets being left
behind
how did that dealt with is aspca dealing
with that
what are you hearing on that front
of course when we first arrive we do we
call a primary search and a secondary
search
so we see that devastation to the
building that's still standing
uh when we first arrived our units did
immediate searches
immediate removals in regards from
balconies wherever we found individuals
we searched each year so every unit that
were able to gain access if not through
the primary which is the first time we
go through
it's our secondary service so we search
through there as well
obviously we're looking for for live
victims
individuals but obviously if we come
across a pet we would move them as well
uh we have it so we didn't come across
any
animals as we went through any types of
pets uh they're in our primary and
secondary so we know that part of it's
been searched
uh other than that you know that's all i
can confirm in regards to hospital
events
there's many more to get to well the
fact that you can't access
now the fact that we went through on our
primary and secondary we
would have came across
thank you i'm sorry yes yes and another
aspect
you know when we went through there uh
the building itself again
in our line of work is as fire rescue
professionals my indeed firefighters
again the first unit i'm seeing
as a fire chief i couldn't be proud of
when i looked to see what we did
and even now and i got here probably
about 45 minutes into the incident
and when i see what we put ourselves in
wow wow um
you know the rescue efforts that we did
uh what we went through going on those
initial first hours of this environment
at 1 30 in the morning 120 when this
came 124 when this call came in
and just non-stop throughout and we've
been non-stop since
non-stop since miami-dade fire rescue
miami-dade county
all our local resources within
miami-dade county all our florida
resources come in with our task force
with our federal
teams coming on standby and that's where
we emphasize i mean we see
the magnitude of this damage we see
and that building collapsed almost in
the footprint
where that building stood it took about
12 stories
we're subterrane with garages all within
that same footprint
so i'm just trying to emphasize the
magnitude of what we're encountering
what we're seeing and we still keep
pushing
forward so yes i mean we definitely
searched and went through and the safety
issues i'm sorry
and the other chair as well i mean
there's definitely structural issues and
i kind of went off topic there
we can't go back in the building okay we
have
with our usar teams they're structural
engineers we have engineers our site
we're now the federal uh instant support
team arriving they also will assist with
the engineer component
and right now it's a we will not go back
in that building
you know we have a section cordoned off
away from that building uh that we won't
search in this way
okay so there's definitely concerns on
all aspects
and we keep going
thank you chief followed by the ap
governor can you tell us about your
meeting
okay so the questions about meeting with
the chief of police for north bay
village who's uh
i think she was 93 year old mother
was uh what was in the towers and um
it was on the one hand heartbreaking
because this is somebody that he had
just dropped off
uh back to her home just uh i think two
days before
uh before the collapse uh but it was
also inspiring because i could see
the difference that she made in his life
in his wife's life and in her grandkids
life
and i think that that
um the life that that she led and
uh for all these years and and obviously
you know
no one's given up hope but um you see
that those types of stories replicated
throughout
uh with these families and um
none of these tragedies are ever easy uh
it's very difficult to see
somebody who's just asleep in their bed
and then you get news that their
building just collapsed
and then you're waiting to see what
what is the resolution can they be saved
can they be identified
and many of these families obviously are
waiting these guys are working their
tails off
and as the fire chief said it is a very
difficult scene
and they are leaving no stone unturned
and they're going to continue to do that
but it's been a very very difficult time
and i think the grief has been
in some respects unique just given the
scale of the tragedy
but um man i was inspired just uh just
just talking with him and you could tell
what he's been able to do
what his kids have been able to do very
successful family
and it all traced back to that matriarch
and uh god bless her and god bless that
family
mayor marquette mentioned that there was
debris falling from the building this
morning
was that new is it getting worse does
that indicate that there might be some
shift in the remainder of the building
that you guys are worried about
well in regards to the building itself
we're constantly monitoring
so no we haven't seen any shift at all
so we have
a special technology that's measuring to
make sure there's not
any shift so that's that's a constant in
regards to debris falling
i wasn't brief what transpired there as
i mentioned there's that 45-foot area
that we're not which is next to the
building uh that we are not working in
because of the overhangs though the
hazards that we have over here
are called the couples they are
specialized in these situations
are here and voluntarily willing to yes
and and we we are accepting their help
thank you so much yes
yes yes thank you so much
okay excuse me just to clarify as was
said here before
we have so many groups on standby
and that is part of their uh that's what
we're seeking from them
we are circulating we're rotating groups
in there are
210 people on the mound we can't put
anybody else on the mount so we're
circulating in
and they are part
is
we've been told that two thousand
buildings are overdue for the 40-year
certification here in the county have
you heard that no ma'am i do not have
that number can you give us an update on
the audit so
far um so
we reported it out this morning uh
it was in the order of 40
something that were due they've all been
under review uh we produced a list of
those that we find
that uh need to have their issues
addressed
they uh mostly their electrical issues
not structural and as you heard earlier
we have directed a unit with four
balconies
to evacuate those those areas
the last last two questions going to be
the gentleman in the black and the lady
over here
for the governor if you guys can talk
about whether or not there's an
accurate number of how many foreign
nationals were in the building
and how many were among the unaccounted
or confirmed
also how many foreign nationals need to
be given the visas and what going to
help these families
well i'll answer first to say that
obviously we have a fluid list
of those who are still on identity
unaccounted for and they definitely
include foreign nationals
it is a fluid list so we can't say it's
a final list and we've been in touch
with the consulates
uh for the various countries represented
and we are working with the state
department as well
[Music]
thank you the last question right here
before we go to creole channel 10.
correct correct so fema is supporting
all of the families at this point
obviously there but maybe some things
down the line that they would not be
eligible but fortunately for us because
of the outpouring of incredible support
1.6 million dollars already donated we
are making sure that everybody who needs
assistance will get it
thank you madam mayor we're going to go
straight into the creole translation
we're going to go into the creole
translation
now we've been we've been instructed to
go straight into the creole now
[Music]
now level for the boom
continuation
[Music]
yes
okay